chuck i gotta
i got something tight my color oh oh you
know what
neil i'm sorry but this conversation
won't work because
i don't see color she
so that's just who i am i'm sorry
okay you know you might want to go find
some other person tell your racist tale
too
so uh color is a huge subject and it's
way more
than i can cover in this
uh short video but a couple of things i
just want you to know that we
in my my people my astrophysics
community
we think about color all the time yeah
that's why
i kind of noticed that no we can
we can it's one of the bits of
information you get from an object at a
distance because you can't go there
i thought you were talking about every
time we go somewhere you're the only
black astrophysicist
we've got a few more there's a few more
there yeah okay go ahead um
so uh
so you can see bits of information that
you're getting from an
object that yeah exactly so so we can
know how bright it is you can know where
it is on the sky
you can detect if it's moving and you
can take its light and break it up into
its spectrum
into its rainbow and you can see how
many different colors
compose the light that you see because
your eye doesn't break it up into the
spectrum
the way that the visor does jordy's
visor
in star trek next generation next
generation
yeah jordy sees all bands of light and
all the entire spectrum
which is a far more superior form of
sight than what we have
what we have we take light we it blends
all into one
sort of quote color image but
there are ways to split it all apart in
case something is revealing itself in
one place and not another
you can identify certain chemical
features in an object
all right that's not even why i'm i'm
bringing this up i'm just saying
we care and think a lot about the colors
of things all right
do you remember was it what color is the
dress what was that thing that yes
that was a um a youtube sensation not
youtube
okay it was a energy social media yeah
okay
so if you you would either see a blue
dress or a gold dress
but it was basically white supposedly
yeah so
so the point there is um i don't
care what you see
i care what it is so i would get a
device out that measured
how much light energy is coming from
that dress
in each of the bits of the spectrum and
then i can quantify that and
give a quantified exact measure of what
the color is
by the way the by the way the the
internet websites do that callers are
numbers okay
yes it's a combination of numbers and
that's the color
i don't care what your your rods and
cones and your retina are doing i don't
care what your state of mind is i don't
care if you're on lsd
right that is a color and it's highly
reproducible
when you have it defined yeah that way
that way you don't look at the gradient
and say well that looks like
it might be it it's like no it's 362.
exactly exactly and so i can take a
machine that's why
the triumphs of science in modern times
or since galileo
you can measure the triumphs of science
by how
effectively it has replaced our
physiological senses that we have been
using before then
so the telescope replaces and microscope
replace our eyes to see
far away things and small things and dim
things and so
so when you improve our senses you can
make discoveries that
we could not have made otherwise all
right so that's why the color of the
dress i just thought all right
people you can fight over it but the
scientists aren't fighting over the
color of the dress
all right so here's here's the point i
want to make
if you have an apple okay traditional
apple what color is it
red right okay so you say the apple is
red
let me hear you utter that sentence the
apple is red okay
so the very construction of that
sentence implies that you are describing
something
intrinsic an intrinsic property of that
apple
right am i would i be wrong to say that
it's making that what the apple
possesses that possesses that call and
the apple is round
you can say things about it that are the
properties of the apple
okay here's a problem
the only way you know the apple is red
is because any red light
that was in the white light that's
illuminating it because white as shown
by isaac newton
is comprised of red orange yellow green
blue
indigo violet all right so so
white light is composed of colors that's
good because when you illuminate a scene
with white light
the red things reflect the red the blue
things it's ripped it's
it's using all of those colors in the
rainbow
to reveal what color they are okay
that's why things are different colors
in a room it's because your source of
light is white
that contains all those colors available
to it
okay so here's my point so white light
is the color police
i get it it's the crown i get it
why is everything got to be the white
light
the white the blue white light is
identifying
all the other things is calling out your
color
calling the dog i got you kids calling
out the white
i'm sorry apple we had to pull you over
you fit the description the description
of what the
somebody said they just saw something
red that's all the red things
that's all we needed that's all we
needed
it's already it was red uh gotta get
that apple
gotta go get that out it's red
right yeah oh oh why i gotta be an apple
[Laughter]
so anyway all right so white white light
is
basically letting everything tell
tell what it is by reflecting back to it
can i watch
okay so here comes the white light upon
the apple
okay
okay sorry okay here it comes now
the only reason why the apple is red
is because it rejected the red
that it was fed oh
gotcha and absorbed all other colors
colors in the spectrum so the rejection
of the red is what we're seeing
with our eyes correct that's why we call
it red
you call it red because that's not what
it is
right that's what it sent back to you
right okay there's no red in around
among that apple because the apple sent
it back to you
so the our very language that says the
apple
is red is logically
flawed given what i'm telling you about
light
the apple is the orange yellow green
blue indigo violet
that's got stuck into the skin of the
apple that's all absorbed into it
that's what it is what it isn't is red
as it inherent property wow
wow wow it's weird now we can just
accept
just colloquially that a red object
is red right we can just say that
but i'm just saying if you go to the
surface molecules of the red object
there is no red there right it all got
sent back to you that's amazing
it's i love it because it's like you say
um it's red is really the reference
it's not what it is it's not what it is
it's not what it is
it's the reference wow
so i just thought i'd tell you that and
by the way if you
have light that contains no red in it
okay okay so you could take sort of um
what they used to call black light so an
ultraviolet light
lights yeah or or very pure um
a tube light like a um like do they
still have the sodium lamps not the
like the ones that are very yellow um
the very yellow sodium lamps in the
streets
i don't know if they still have those
not anymore but you you'll find them in
like older places in older places right
so what you do is
take an apple and bring it up to that
lamp
you know what color the apple is no
red and yellow no no it can't be red
because the light source has no red
no i'm saying what's that what's that
what does that make so
oh what no no i'm saying give it a light
source that contains no red
oh okay and bring apple into that light
source
oh i don't know what color it'll be the
apple will be black
black now see
black see now it absorbs
if it absorbs the colors then nothing's
coming back to your eyes yeah well
see that's how that works no here's the
problem with that man
okay don't know if i don't know don't
nobody want no black apple
don't tell nobody want no black apple
okay now i'm just saying
and you know i i i love
listen i love black i love black i love
being black
i love you okay but you ain't in a black
eyes
i forgot when you say all the colors
because i forgot black is the mixture of
all colors no no black is the absence of
the absence of
all colors so yeah so if nothing no
right all right
white is all the colors black and light
right together absolutely all colors
gone
right so if right that's what you would
when you mix all the colors of light
the fact that they make white is a
little freaky to the artist it's a
little freaky
it is a little because when they mix
paint it doesn't you don't get white but
light mixed together you get white light
right all those colors and if you colors
are not coming to your eye the thing
just
becomes black there it is you know and
it's so
funny because i knowing that i know
i'm still can't see the black apple
because i
and i know that black is the absence of
color
and i'm still trying to think like the
only absence of code is the absence of
light that's what i mean my point is
white light hits the apple the apple
looks red because it reflects only red
light
absorbed all the other colors now have a
light source with no
red right then it can't nothing's coming
to you
it's got to be black it's got this black
what will happen in the
absence of color with light you will not
see
anything because there's nothing coming
back
correct correct now i get it 100
oh by the way by the way the blue object
will be blue next to it and then other
things there's a yellow and there's a
green
i think the apple goes black right right
that makes perfect sense
let me take it up a notch i could not
get my head around a black
apple clearly you couldn't okay so now
let's take it up a notch
and we got to call it quits okay you
ready go for it um
i did this experiment in a telescope
dome when you're in a telescope at night
we have what's called night lighting
which is very deep red lights
that will still enable you to see the
darkened skies
it's called dark adapting because your
eye goes through this you might notice
um if you wake up in the middle of night
and you put on the bathroom lights
you're like well
i can't you have to dark adapt all right
and once you're dark adapted
everything's fine
we do this at the telescope dome so the
telescope lights tend to be
deep amber and sometimes deep red okay
um i saw a can on the shelves
there's a soda can and there was nothing
written on it
nothing the whole the whole can was red
and it was like how can there be nothing
what what
what what turn on the lights
guess what can it was
uh what color was the the dark adapt yes
it was a red
okay so that would have been hmm
trying to think which the whole can was
red though
the whole camera was red but i saw no
detail on the camera no detail
which is a pure red cam it's like what
this is america
everything we have has a surface with
ads on it and names and products and
everything so you know what it was
coca-cola coca-cola can right is it
coca-cola can
why because the red on the coca-cola can
reflects what the red light the red
light
the white on the coca-cola can reflects
what
um
[Music]
wow okay wait a minute oh the white
light so right right no
what is it white is wait a minute now
i'm confused because he
got me okay so so white light reflects
all colors
that's what i said all all of because
it's white light but i'm not handing it
all colors
right your own oh that's i forgot we're
in the dark adapt yes so there you go
so the point is the red reflected the
red light
that's it the white reflected the red
light right
so there was no contrast between the two
the two
right and all of the printing on that
can disappeared
that's kind of cool very cool i like
that
very good we should send this to
coca-cola
now there's a friend of mine in college
who uh in our physics class he was
you were allowed to have a single sheet
of handwritten
notes a crib sheet basically for
yourself but it had to fit on this
single sheet of paper
and so that was the rule so everyone
prepared theirs and i saw this guy's
sheet and you couldn't even read it
it was like what did you do so what he
did was
he wrote in three different color pen
inks on top of itself so it doesn't make
a difference
and then he brought the filters filters
to and okay guys let me tell you
something so you got three times as much
information on it i would have given
them an a
just for that
[Laughter]
so chuck that's it uh there's so much
more we can do
five more color episodes but i just want
to get it out there
that an object isn't really its color
please tell that to this one officer
the police department
please you have to turn this into a
black lives matter episode
okay fine please officer i just listened
to dr neil degrasse tyson
he said by the way officer you are
wasting your time
stopping me as a tax-paying white man
because i absorbed all those because i
absorbed all the colors
so all right chuck we got to call it
quits there all righty
good to have you jeff always a pleasure
all right
star talk cosmic explainers
neil degrasse tyson keep looking out
you